welcome to program your remote today
we're going to be taking a look at a
ford f-150 smart key programming
procedure i'm going to be demonstrating
on an expedition in the video but it
will be the same on the f-150
this is only going to apply to f-150s
that have a push-button start ignition
if you have a flip key with a regular
turn style ignition your truck will take
a different programming procedure and
i'll put a link to that video in the
description box of this video but in our
case we do have a push button start
ignition
so in order to be able to add a new key
yourself you need two already working
smart keys
which we have right here
unfortunately if you don't have two
currently working keys you will not be
able to add a new one yourself you'll
have to go to a locksmith or automotive
dealership
but in our case we do have our two
working ones here
this is our new one
um you can have the key in the bottom in
or out i just have it out to help me
keep track so i know that this is the
unprogrammed one
so the first thing you want to do is go
over to the cup holder and in the front
cup holder we're going to remove the
rubber piece that's on the bottom
after we remove that piece we can see
what's referred to in your owner's
manual is the backup slot in the bottom
there
so we're going to take our first already
programmed smart key
and we're going to put it in there like
that
then we're going to come over here and
we're going to turn the ignition to the
on position so that's going to be
pressing the stop start button one time
without pressing the brake
we're gonna listen for it to stop
dinging
once it stops dinging turn it off
remove the first key
place your second already programmed key
in there
turn it to on position
wait for it to quit dinging
turn it off
remove that now we're going to grab our
unprogrammed key and put it in there in
the same way
come over here and do the same thing
turn it on
[Music]
and you saw the the hazards flash and
then we got a message there saying keep
program successful
so that's it pretty simple
if you have any questions please let me
know
if you could take a second to like and
subscribe
it helps us out and i'd appreciate it
thank you